hey youtubers it's Charlie so I wanted
to dedicate a video to Doctor Who
companions I've already done a video
about my favorite old companions so I
wanted to talk about people that I
wanted to see become companions at some
point in the future I also have some new
details on the series 8 premiere so I'll
talk about that because I know the most
important thing we want to know right
now is when we can start watching
episodes if you're finding me for the
first time I'm just doing Doctor Who
bonus videos until series 8 premiere be
sure to subscribe to get everything
once it starts I'm just gonna do like I
do for Game of Thrones with the three
regular videos you know like the bonus
video episode review and a QA so it'll
be a lot of fun I'm even doing a special
giveaway every week so important stuff
first
there's a Doctor Who world tour starting
on August 7th in the UK and ending
August 19th and Brazil the BBC announced
that Peter Capaldi and people from the
show will be promoting the series in a
bunch of different cities in
anticipation of the series 8 premiere
that language is very important in
anticipation of series 8 what does that
mean essentially Capaldi is gonna be
travelling around doing press and then
after the tour's over they'll have the
worldwide premiere August 19th is on a
Tuesday the last day of that tour so
tentatively planned for the series 8
premiere to be on Saturday August 23rd
it's totally possible that they could
have the premiere in the middle of the
tour but because they said in
anticipation of I think that they're
gonna wait till after the tour's over to
premiere that first episode I'll post a
link in the description for all those
tour dates in case they're coming to a
city that you live in and you want to
try and go see them so now let's talk
about some companions the fun thing is
there can be a lot of them unless it's
the 50th anniversary or the doctors
having vanity issues that can really
only be one of him in any given episode
but companions come and go all the time
so here are the top 10 people I'd like
to see become companions at some point
in the future number 10 John Bradley
from Game of Thrones Samwell on Doctor
Who would be so much fun there's a lot
of historical figures he could play like
young Winston Churchill but as a
companion I'd really like to see him
play a grownup version of Stormageddon
he's already playing a good analog for
Craig on Game of Thrones plus he could
be part of the meta sci-fi mashup with a
bunch of other Game of Thrones actors
that are on my list one of the things I
really like about UK series or series
that film in Europe are that actors
bounce around a lot so actors that show
up on Doctor Who together tend to show
up on other shows together too number 9
Antonia Thomas from misfits
so she's actually just been cast in
series two of the Musketeers which also
stars Peter Capaldi he's obviously gonna
have to leave that show just because of
Doctor Who commitments but see what I
mean about actors working together on
different shows it's really her
character on misfits that made me put
her on this list if he never saw that
series it's basically about a bunch of
juvenile delinquents they get caught in
a storm and get superpowers her
superpower was sexual attraction
she had like River Song levels of
pheromones so she would just be amazing
as a companion on Doctor Who that may or
may not have been the daughter of River
Song
I know Jenny's supposed to be the
doctor's daughter but it's funny to
think about an alternate universe
version of her that took after a River
Song more also fun fact another game of
Thrones actors that start with Antonia
on misfits was a win' rayon he basically
plays Ramsay snow Ramsay Bolton now on
the show number eight free I'm a
from skins on skin she went from being
like a mean girl queen bee to a mother
and a caregiver you could say that all
of the doctors female companions end up
taking care of him at some point so I'd
really like to see her get something of
a modified Donna Noble arc where she
goes from like meltdown celebutant to
hero obviously Donna was never to love
you Tom but you get the idea remember
between series six and seven when any
pond had that whole art where she became
this huge celebrity and head of
falling-out with Rory think of it as
something like that I wasn't a huge fan
of that but somatically I think it could
work
Freya as the celebrity just getting
swept up in the doctor's life fun fact
Freya was on skins with fellow Game of
Thrones actors Hannah Murray and Joe
Dempsie they played Gilly and gantry
respectively
number seven Ruth Wilson from Luther
she's a little bit older than the
20-something actresses that doctor who
usually casts as companions but I really
wanted to include a few fantasy picks
for actors who are just amazing on
Luther her Alice character is incredibly
sinister like River Song when she was
still the insane version of melody pond
she'd even make a fantastic Lady Time
Lord I think given the darker and more
serious tone of Capaldi's doctor she'd
be a really good foil though you don't
always have to have silly companions so
she's my choice for like a devilish grin
companion not an evil one just one that
delights in little chaos if you never
saw her on Luther she actually starred
on that show with Paul McGann he was in
like eight episodes so she should check
it out
number six Hannah Murray from Game of
Thrones I just want to see Gilly become
a
Doctor Who companion that's that's what
I'm saying like Samwell finds her a new
place to hide that just ends up being a
police box
conveniently parked in the library of
Castle black she was also on skins with
Joe Dempsey but her character Cassie
Ainsworth was just a total fail of a
human being the doctor is supposed to be
a healer so I'd really like to see
Hannah do a version of Cassie that
becomes you know empowered as a result
of her adventures in the TARDIS not
empowered like bad wolf empowered but
you get the idea like a fun twist on the
hero's journey that you usually see the
doctor get you know you go from like
Lois point to like superhero at the end
number five Laura Donnelly from Merlin
on that show she played the character
who became the Lady of the lake she was
a tragic character who was cursed and
fell in love with Merlin but eventually
ascended to become this hugely important
character I know it sounds a lot like
bad wolf Rose Tyler I don't want to see
another romantic companion so soon after
River Song but I do like the idea of the
ticking clock they kind of did it with
Clara and the impossible girl plot but
I'd like to see Laura play Campania the
doctor always knows will die very very
soon like a reverse version of the Lake
Silencio plot during series 6 where the
doctor always has to die in a certain
time in place so they just had to use
time travel to avoid that moment for the
whole series until eventually the doctor
has to take her back and she ends up
dying so fun fact Merlin is actually a
real medicine that has a bunch of Doctor
Who and Game of Thrones crossovers so
she was on that show with Eve miles from
Torchwood Joe Dempsie from Game of
Thrones and John Hurt who is the
eight-point-five doctor or the Ninth
Doctor depending on how you want to look
at it number four Rose Leslie I don't
want to post any Game of Thrones
spoilers about Egrets character here but
I'm such a fan of the previouse ginger
companion that I really want to see Rose
Leslie be like the Ygritte to the
doctors Jon Snow not in a romantic way
just a companion that isn't gonna take
any of the doctors crap I always feel
like my favorite companions are smarter
than the doctor Early's more helpful yes
the doctor always comes through in the
end but day to day it's the companion
that usually ends up seeming like the
smart one Rose Leslie would make an
amazing companion who could kind of boss
the doctor around without seeming too
unlikable number three Karla crome from
misfits on that show her superpower was
seeing through people's like
when they were lying I'd really like to
see how that ability would work
the doctors first rule is the doctor
always lies just imagine Capaldi saying
random things and off in the distance
you hearing her say are just
really softly under her breath it'd be
so funny number two
Richard IUD he was actually rumored for
the role of the doctor a long time ago
but I'm glad they didn't cast them just
because Matt Smith's thing was being the
sillier version of the doctor and IU
idea is an excellent comedian but a
comedy driven doctor for six to eight
years in a row it's just way too much of
the same that's why I really want to see
him as a companion you know someone who
can just punch up Capaldi when he gets
just a little too dry or a little too
dark that's the thing I really love
about British humor sometimes it can be
so subtle you don't even realise that
it's a joke but most of the time I think
that that kind of humor ends up being
funnier than the really obvious jokes
you seen stuff like 22 Jump Street
there's at least like one dick joke
every five minutes and yeah I left a lot
but I think I you IDs dry humor would be
so much more appropriate for Doctor Who
I mean why else would they have
considered him for the role of the
doctor if he wasn't perfect for the
series and the number one person I want
to see become a companion in the future
Kate McGrath from Merlyn she plays
Morgana
on Merlyn but I think she would make an
amazing Doctor Who companion she would
be my dream casting like a companion who
could run circles around the doctor I
feel like all the best companions would
make amazing Time Lords so whenever
you're considering people that you want
to be new companions you have to
consider people that could be a Time
Lord potentially in order to do that
convincingly you have to be both
powerful and really quick like Stephen
Colbert quick mentally that is like a
machine gun of thought I know a lot of
you Game of Thrones fans would love to
see her play Lyanna Stark and some sort
of flashback scene but there is no
reason that she could not do both
there's like three Game of Thrones
actors on my list here one of the
benefits of British series running
shorter than American series is that it
leaves more time for the actors to do
other shows so Morgana Pendragon gets my
number one vote for a future companion
now it's your turn though let me know in
the comments below who do you want to
see become a future Doctor Who companion
bonus points if you can cross the fandom
streams since I'm posting this kind of
late I'm not gonna have time to do
orphan black tonight so I'm just going
to be doing some tumblr gifs and posting
my thoughts there you're also welcome to
ask any questions about that in these
comments my next Doctor Who video is
gonna post next Saturday I haven't
completely decided what it's gonna be
but feel free to leave me suggestions
right now though click here to catch up
on Game of Thrones and get ready for the
big finale this weekend and click here
to learn more about the series 8
episodes thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you